ces moments
atelier de baby basket à guyancourt pour
les 4-5 ans la commune accueille chaque
année cet événement organisé par la
fédération de basket des yvelines 112
enfants étaient réunis issus de quatorze
clubs du sud du département on est fier
d'accueillir cet événement parce que
c'est ça fait bouger notre ville en
premier et puis notre club donc c'est
simplement pour ont stimulé un peu
l'effet basket au sein du département
voilà je t'aime bien ce soit parce que
j'aime bien ce tg à de sport j'aime bien
courir qu'est ce que tu aimes bien dans
le basket
face
pourquoi tu amiens de bastia
actuel est trop bien
on travaille beaucoup sur le dribble
donc on leur fait faire des slaloms
le jeu du miroir on dribble et hydrique
devant nous pour les passes ont fait des
passes à dix cd sort de match quand même
mais sandrine que des passes jeux et
exercices pour donner aux enfants un
esprit d'équipé et peut-être faire
naître des vocations